what's up young back with mike ebbs and
wanda sykes give it up
so wanda and mike have a new sitcom on
netflix called the upshaws
and over the years sitcoms have brought
us dozens of awesome one-liners and
catch phrases that i really hope i
remember right now
uh but how well do wanda and i know
which catchphrase comes from which
sitcom
um it's time to find out with a game
called yabba dabba do you know the show
get it
we're clever yeah we are the show
here's the actual best part i literally
didn't know what yabba dabadoo was from
and
yeah so i'm gonna do well at this game i
didn't know i didn't watch the
flintstones
don't tell anyone i know mike ebbs has
graciously agreed to host
um since i don't even know what yabba
daba do is um so tell us how the game
works
okay this is how the game goes it's
simple kelly
okay i'm gonna read a phrase a famous
phrase from a classic sitcom and you and
wanda
would hit the button to say the name of
the show
okay all right i feel like i'm going to
do better than not knowing the title
yeah but that dude now don't get back
okay
if you're wrong the other person can
steal it oh okay that's that's how it
gonna go
okay wanda's playing from the right side
of the audience and kelly you playing
from the left side okay
and the winner gets a prize of her for
her side
okay okay okay here we go all right
first catch phrase is
how you doing oh how you doing joey
tribiani friends
oh my god i feel good i'm very
competitive let me just warn you
that was pretty good okay this one is a
bit harder than wanda
kelly okay that's what she said
what that's the office
oh damn why i couldn't
[Applause]
okay i sounded like a next one she went
to the zoo
they killed kenny you bastards south
park
[Applause]
okay
what you talking about willis different
strokes
yeah anyway i know the song can play
that game damn it
you sound pretty good all right as well
okay here we go here we go
the next one she's quick no soup for you
that's seinfeld oh my god no soup are
you next in line
yeah yes okay
well that's a pretty i knew that one
i've seen that show dominating but it
looked like she's trying to she's trying
to come back
okay dine oh my god
she's quick okay
i haven't watched
that sound means this is the last
question
the one's worth five points
yeah that's where i can last one
i'm ready okay d.o
[Music]
that's homosexual what the hell just
happened
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
d oh and then she got it before i you
know what this
oh got it i know okay the winner is
wanda that's so amazing
i'm just kidding you know what you
stand over there that means that on the
right side of the house seats
wins um a prize and it's my show so you
and as well left side you're welcome
um our friends at life is good are on a
mission to inspire people to choose
optimism
to positively impact their lives in the
lives of others
they do this through positive art and
messages on a broad variety of apparel
partnership products and most
importantly
an ever-growing community of inspiring
optimists everyone in the house seats
is getting a 300 gift card to life is
good
um and since wanda won so fairly um her
photo will
be mounted on the she wouldn't beat me
anyway um
her photo's going to be mounted on the
blake shelton wall of champions who beat
kelly clarkson so damn you want her
yes it's only there's only a few wanda
okay
there's a lot whatever be sure to check
out wanda and mike in their new show the
upshaws on netflix right now
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around
my head this one is really cool i'm just
saying
no pressure